impeachment inquiry gave notice today
that they will be sending a subpoena to
the White House for documents and other
materials will you cooperate with those
subpoenas
well I always cooperate this is a hoax
this is the greatest hoax this is just a
continuation of what's been playing out
John for the last since my election I
would say if you want to probably will
find out soon but probably even before
my election this is a fraudulent crime
on the American people but we'll work
together with shifty shift and Pelosi
and all of them and we'll see what
happens because we did absolutely I had
a great call with the president of
Ukraine it was a hundred percent you
have the transcript and then shift went
up and he got as the chairman of the
committee got up and related a call that
didn't take place he made up the
language I'm hard to believe nobody has
ever seen this I think he had some kind
of a mental breakdown but he went up to
the microphone and he read a statement
from the President of the United States
as if I were on the call because what
happened is when he looked at the sheet
which was an exact transcript of my call
done by very talented people that do
this exact word for word he said Wow he
didn't do anything wrong so he made it
up he went up to a microphone and in
front of the American people and in
Congress he went out and he he gave a
whole presentation of words that the
President of the United States never
said it has to be a criminal act it has
to be and he should resign and some
people even say it was treason but it
was a very sad thing just so you know
the call was perfect the real call the
call I made many people were on the line
I knew that because usually when I speak
to foreign country leaders you can name
any one of them but when I speak on the
phone I know that we have many people
listening from various intelligence
agencies my knowledge I know all about
it and so this isn't something like oh
gee I'm on the line let's talk about a
big secret this is many people on the
line I don't even know how many we'll
find out I guess
but many people Mike Pompeo is on though
I didn't say anything he just because
they listened for both knowledge and for
security reasons and for lots of reasons
but the president of Ukraine at the
United Nations the other day and
previous to that he announced through
his spokesperson said there was
absolutely no pressure put on him
there was no quid pro quo at all and if
you look at this whistle blowers which I
have a lot of respectful whistle blows
but only when they're real his report of
the phone call was totally different
than the fact but what got them was they
never thought I was going to release the
call because I don't like doing that I
don't want to do I hope I don't have to
do it again release phone calls to
foreign dignitaries to foreign leaders I
don't want to do that John I don't want
to do it again but I did it with the
permission of the Ukrainian government
we got permission we called up their
representatives and asked them would it
be okay
otherwise that couldn't have done it and
if I wouldn't have done it I would have
been exposed to a lie because the
whistleblower report didn't he say seven
or eight times I said quid pro quo in
other words you're gonna do this or
you're not going to get money now in all
fairness Buyten said it and he's on tape
in all fairness you have at least four
United States senators Democrats that
said it and they said it a lot stronger
than even Schiff and is made-up story
and said it Obama when he was dealing
with the President of Russia met Putin
he said hey tell Lattimer I can do a lot
more after the election you remember
that you didn't make a big deal out of
that everybody thought oh isn't that
cute
isn't that cute my talk and my response
Lindsey Graham said I never knew you
were that nice I can't believe you were
that nice he said that loud and clear it
was perfect
it was perfect not a thing wrong with it
to impeach a president over a fraud that
was committed by other people that want
to win an election in 2020 which they
won't is incredible this is the greatest
hoax now it's gone on for a long time
we had the Muller collusion delusion
okay that went on for years and that's
finally done no collusion no obstruction
no nothing it was a joke and everyone
knows it and it was from the day one now
I get three days of peace and I'm
walking into the United Nations gonna
meet with the biggest leaders in the
world and I hear about the word
impeachment I said what did I do now and
it was about a beautiful conversation
that I had and just remember this the
Ukrainian new president a fine man said
I don't know what you're talking about
there was no pressure and he said it a
number of times okay what's your second
question just what you shouldn't be
asking two questions well you're gonna
want to answer me a favor yes ask one of
the I will finish done I think you want
to ask John Square ask one of the
Finnish president can I come back to you
because I think you'll want to talk
later sure well it sounds like it might
be a good question let me see if I like
the question go ahead there may be for
the first time in three years I'll have
a good question and I'll love it there
is a report that came out just before
you and president Nene still walked out
here that the whistleblower met with a
staff member of Adam Schiff I love that
question being filed it shows that
Schiff is a fraud and I I love that
question thank you Joe
can I finish asking it yes there's
nothing to finish so so the
whistleblower according to this report
meant with the member of staff
Adam shifts staff you got it right there
you know it I hate to say it so New York
Times I can't believe they wrote it your
response to maybe they're getting better
your response to the fact that that
happened and the shift may have learned
some of what the whistleblower knew
prior to the complete it's a scandal
that he knew before I go a step further
I think you probably helped write it
okay that's what the word is and I think
it's I give a lot of respect for the New
York Times for putting it out just
happened as I'm walking up here they
handed it to me and I said to Mike I
said whoa that's something that's big
stuff that's a big story
he knew long before and he helped write
it too it's a scam it's a scam just to
finish on this I appreciate it I love
that second question by the
should have asked at first but but let
me just tell you the whole thing is a
scam
the Muller deal was a scam the Russian
collusion was a scam
you can ask Putin nobody's been rougher
on Russia than Donald Trump okay now
with that being said it'd be great to
get along with Russia and we will get
along with Russia because it's smart but
nobody's been tougher on Russia than
Donald Trump okay
s1 please yes president